[Music]
they saw the end of the world I could
feel all this death Jean it was just a
dream
[Music]
I've been called many things are many
lifetimes right
Krishna Yahweh ever since the world
found out about mutants there have been
secret societies who see them as some
kind of second coming or sign of God
they believe that tens of thousands of
years ago ancient being was born the
world's first mutant you are all and a
lost
because you follow blind leaders
man now I'm here for you
wherever this being was he always had 4
followers he would imbue with power like
the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
you got that one from the Bible or the
Bible got it from him what is it
Oh God he can control all of us
the world needs the x-men that's why I'm
here to fight
[Music]
not all of us can control our powers
then don't this is war
everything they feel
we fall and from the ashes of their
world
we'll build up that's a one
I've never felt like this before
[Music]
hey youtubers it's Charlie so we finally
get to see an x-men apocalypse trailer
survival of the fittest battle royale so
let's get going so a lot of you may have
read the Age of Apocalypse comic book
marvel brought it back during Secret
Wars this isn't based on that they
didn't really adapt any specific
storyline Bryan Singer's a big comic
book geek so a lot of the things you see
will just be familiar to the Age of
Apocalypse comic book but it's not gonna
be like an exact storyline but we open
on our brand-new Jean Grey sophie turner
flashing forward seeing images of
Apocalypse all the destruction that he
is going to wreak I know the minute she
was cast everybody was wondering about a
Dark Phoenix storyline sometime in the
future this is taking place in the 80s
so this is young Jean Grey this gonna be
young Nightcrawler young storm they're
transitioning to new versions of all
these characters so I definitely totally
think they'll do some Dark Phoenix
storyline with sophie turner sometime in
the future and yes Bryan Singer did
announce that he was coming back for the
next x-men film so you know whatever
that ends up being he will be part of it
if you didn't know this film takes place
in the 80s this Professor X hairdo will
do it for you and yes I mean obviously
he's totally going bald in the film but
if Days of Future past was a 70s x-men
film thinking this is 80s x-men film and
you can kind of see why they're not
doing the exact Age of Apocalypse
storyline because that was kind of
another darkest timeline story and they
just did that in Days of Future past so
like they they want to do something
that's a little bit different so then I
can be flashing forward they're mostly
going to be flashing back Jean Grey
flashing forward to death and
destruction is about as close as we're
gonna get to future time travel and
finally we get to see Mohawk storm I'm
so excited about Mohawk storm right now
she is my favorite x-men based on a
character that we've already seen a
bunch of times via Halle Berry hooded
figure obviously apocalypse going around
seeking his four horsemen now apocalypse
showed up for the first time in x-factor
number five back in 1986 but one of the
really cool things about apocalypse just
as a character was that he was
co-created by a female comic book Raider
almost every single comic book movie
that has been made has been based on
characters created by male creators
Louise Simonson was the female creator
responsible for bringing him into the
book so they came up with the idea of
apocalypse like the villain behind the
villains and right from that first
appearance his mantra was survival of
the fittest so it's been there since the
very beginning they didn't reveal that
his name was in Sabah nur till cable
number
that was in 1993 so way way later it's a
little bit like what they did with
Ultron like whenever they first
introduced the Ultron character they
didn't reveal his backstory till many
issues later he just showed up as this
menacing villain menacing the Avengers
so apocalypse shows up an x-factor
scares the [ __ ] out of everybody and
then we learn his backstory much much
later most of you have probably seen the
cartoon version from the 90s x-men
cartoon series you should actually go
back and re-watch that sometime this
weekend but he has a giant list of
powers not sure they're gonna do every
single one of them in the film but it
seems like they are because they say he
can control all of us so it actually
looks like he uses Professor X to speak
to all the mutants on the planet to find
them because he's trying to find his
children working down the list though he
has molecular manipulation that's how he
makes himself grow immortality
super-strength energy manipulation a
genius-level mind techno pathy meaning
he can control electronic circuits
transmutation and DNA manipulation in
case you haven't read the comics he
usually wears special armor so he has
this blue cast to him he has normal skin
and then he puts this armor on later if
you remember the post-credits scene from
Days of Future past he looks like that
as a child when he's not wearing the
armor like until his powers fully
activate but if you want to read a
really cool story with him more recently
there's a clone of apocalypse that
they've named Evan who slowly learns
about his heritage I'm like a copy of
this really crazy villain that you guys
have fought for a long time during the
axis storyline his powers are activated
so he goes from being this really good
child to the crazy villain apocalypse
that we know and love the survival of
the fittest apocalypse the excess comic
leaves it in really interesting way he
gets tied up with Deadpool's character
speaking of which there's a Deadpool
trailer coming really soon so keep your
eyes peeled for that but this is mostly
about x-men stuff but if you're looking
for a really fun twist on the apocalypse
character and you've already read Age of
Apocalypse then just read the lead-up to
x-men access that storyline starts
around Wolverine in the x-men number 4
back in 2012 so it's relatively recent
Deadpool and apocalypse just Pallin
around town fictional character
biography though they call him the first
mutant but he was really born about
5,000 years ago it sounds like it's
longer than it actually was because you
have to remember that humans are not as
old as the planets like the planet is
billions of years old humanity isn't
that old but because he was born looking
deformed nobody really understood what
the x-gene was five
thousand years ago his people abandoned
him he was found by Raiders and they
were the ones who instilled the idea of
survival of the fittest in him as a
child
so all this backstory is dealt with in
rise up apocalypse it's like its own
miniseries so you should definitely read
that too if you want to learn about
apocalypse his backstory but the big
twist where he armors up totally jumps
himself forward is where he runs into
the spaceship from the future now the
interesting thing is that it belonged to
King the Conqueror who had come back in
time but he finds that it's disguised as
the Sphinx so I mean it's all based on
Egyptian mythology they find Kang the
Conqueror inside the spaceship getting
ready to die nurse him back to health he
becomes one of the Pharaohs of Egypt now
obviously we're getting into a little
bit of Bible mythology like if you're
starting to recognize some of the
symbolism but you can think of
apocalypse in this storyline the origin
story as the future King David character
who supplants King Saul eventually ends
up bringing the Ark of the Covenant to
Jerusalem in Apocalypse the spaceship is
like the Ark now this is all comic books
they're gonna be a lot of changes to
this but essentially in his origin story
apocalypse is the protagonist so of
course came the conquer is the Saul
character the technology that apocalypse
gains access to was left by the
Celestials now if you remember the
Celestials they were briefly mentioned
during Marvel's guardians of the galaxy
film thinking them is all powerful
cosmic ancient beings that have been
around since the dawn of time but they
debuted during Eternals number one so if
you want to read more about the
Celestials they're in that book but
apocalypses origin story is all about
his coming-of-age tale and how his power
is fully emerged in ancient Egypt really
cool side note I know a lot of people
are hoping to see mr. sinister at a
certain point apocalypse is responsible
for transforming Nathaniel Essex into
mr. sinister they kind of deal with this
in the trailer in that apocalypse is
responsible for a lot of the big shifts
in humanity like every once in a while
in history when he feels like he's
needed he'll wake up proclaims survival
of the fittest wipe the slate clean and
rebuild with the mutants that are left
in the ashes
so when apocalypse comes into this film
it's not the first time that he's done
this and he's been successful every
single time here's havoc from the
previous x-men films we've seen him
before but we also get to see the new
version of Cyclops his brother from the
comics flashing back to ancient Egypt
telling a little bit about apocalypse as
origin story yay Moira MacTaggert back
though I'm so
be that Rose Byrne is back she's such an
awesome actress but her character just
doesn't have a lot to do when it's open
war in the streets with superpowers
beast is back and this is actually kind
of funny Jennifer Lawrence here's
mystique this is actually gonna be her
last x-men film it looks like she might
be an activist at this point unless
she's in like some sort of hippie prayer
circle I'm getting I'm guessing she's
become more proactive because of her
role in this film she seems like the
super mutant that everyone rallies
behind who do not drink apocalypse as
kool-aid
we get to see Nightcrawler Kodi
smit-mcphee for the first time now in
the comics he's mystique son I don't
know if that's gonna be the case in this
film Jubilee huge character from the 90s
animated series in the comics she was
actually introduced to replace shadow
cat or Kitty Pryde who everyone to think
about her Kitty Pryde had gone on to
Excalibur so they wanted a new character
that kind of had that same energy so
they brought in Jubilee is like the kid
on the team still has the hair then
apocalypse and Mohawk storm fine magneto
the premise of his character before the
film the setup is kind of funny he's
completely checked out if you remember
what happened at the end of Days of
Future Passed he essentially got his ass
handed to him publicly on television so
he has absolutely no idea what's going
on with his life like he's completely
lost so that's when apocalypse shows up
and says hey I totally have a plan why
don't you follow my plan if you don't
know what to do so in the trailer I know
they're teasing new Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse like storm might be a
Horsemen of the Apocalypse
angel might be one of the other horsemen
did you have characters listed as like
death and plague but do not be surprised
if storm and Magneto become two of his
horsemen depending on which comic you're
reading there have been a bunch of
different x-men that have been
apocalypse as horsemen at various points
and this is the new angel so he's in
this universe now so we'll probably see
him in the next film too if he if he
makes it through this film that is I
don't think they go through the trouble
of all this character development just
to kill him off in the first film though
finally get our first shot of Olivia
Munn as Psylocke most of the time you
know people who aren't super familiar
with her character just remember that
she's one of the few bisexual x-men
characters so during comic-con Olivia
Munn was teasing a lot of people with
that you know just I'm gonna be having a
lot of fun in this movie she even posted
a bunch of pictures of her training with
her sword she uses twin swords now
there's a bit of a misdirect in the
trailer because it makes it seem you
know based on this dialogue that
Professor X is going to be one of the
Horsemen of the Apocalypse
but it just sounds like he gets co-opted
by apocalypse when he says I've never
felt power like this I think
when he is seeking apocalypse out like
when he hears about it for the first
time and he starts looking so he's not
imbued with power he's just sensing
apocalypses power hey Charles mind if we
borrow your machine we need to find some
mutants so obviously here mystique has
put together this x-men team you can see
Jean Grey in the new Cyclops in the
background and Quicksilver Quicksilver
is much bigger in this film Evan Peters
was like oh yeah I definitely get a lot
of fun stuff to do much better shot of
New Kids on the Block with Mama Bear
mystique if you remember during the very
first x-men film Wolverine is the
fish-out-of-water makes fun of their
costumes and they have the joke you know
what would you prefer yellow spandex so
there's always been Easter eggs to the
classic costumes these are just born out
of the very hardcore idea that they are
in open war so they need to wear battle
armor we get to see apocalypse make
himself bigger use his powers a little
bit this looks like it could be from
Jean Grey's flash-forward and then
finally we get bald professor X it looks
like he's going to be going bald just as
a result of the stress of the war with
apocalypse like most of the film he'll
have his 80s hairdo and then he will
finally lose it by the end of the film
but make no mistake there will be
another x-men film with these new
characters you know new angel new Jean
Grey new Cyclops taking the forefront
Bryan Singer will be directing that film
- I don't think that they've announced
when it's going to drop but just
expected in the next two years and the
Wolverine film will fall in between that
like that will come in between this in
the next x-men film that is going to be
Hugh Jackman's last time as the
Wolverine character they haven't said
whether or not he's gonna appear in this
movie I'm expecting like a really small
cameo but he's probably gonna be a big
part of the film they kind of built Days
of Future past around his character so
you can understand why they don't want
to do the exact same thing again they
want you to focus on these new
characters what about Deadpool though he
definitely exists in this x-men universe
but because this is in the 80s it sounds
like they're going to make Deadpool a
much more modern characters so he's
probably still living as Wade Wilson
when this movie picks up let me know in
the comments what is your favorite thing
about this trailer and what is your
favorite apocalypse storyline you know
either from the cartoons or from the
comics and just as a bonus Bryan Singer
was on Twitter answering questions about
the film earlier today so I'm going to
jam all of his answers here so you guys
didn't hear it directly from the horse's
mouth so my bigger film deals with
things like all the level deals with the
history of mutants the ancient history
and has our first trailer and we'll have
another one coming out probably next
year which really even bigger one of the
most exciting parts of this movie is I
get to reintroduce famous characters
Jean Grey Nightcrawler storm
Scott Summers as younger people as
different characters innocent characters
who are just coming into the world of
the excellent while I was very important
for me an injury storm as a street
urchin a kind of innocent you know
supporting the Mohawk from the comic
this in this movie I really wanted to
take us to the comic book more than I've
ever done before the eighties are
particularly exciting for me because
these were my teenage years and I was
excited to you know explore them because
I remember them so well and they were so
happy and I wanted to bring horror and
terror into the happiness of the atheist
well Olivia clearly I'm most excited for
everyone to meet Psylocke she's an
intense character hot character and
design very much like the comic book I
think you and I both had way down on
that and excited for that working with
Jennifer is always awesome she's a great
girl and a fantastic actress and her
character really doesn't want to be a
leader of any kind she wants to work
alone but in this movie she finds
herself in a reluctant leadership
position I should say Alex who's my
favorite horseman well clearly storm I
mean she rides lightning bolts down come
on hey Ben I'm looking at the emojis and
I found yours was a little misleading
he's so adorable and cute like an angel
man reality your characters like the
most sinister evil one
MacAvoy insisted on shaving off his own
hair so we actually have a video of me
holding up my iphone facetiming Patrick
Stewart watching McEvoy shave his own
head and Patrick was like save some of
that hair for me I will be doing a new
Deadpool trailer video of really soon
they might end up dropping one in the
next week or so I'm expecting one before
the end of the year so be sure to
subscribe to get that and if there's any
x-men bonus videos you guys want me to
do just let me know in the comments just
in case you guys haven't seen it I
posted a new Star Wars trailer and a new
Captain America Civil War teaser
yesterday you can click here for Captain
America Civil War and you can click here
for Star Wars
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you